excellent book I think this is really a
an improvement if the if that's even
possible on a masterpiece just like to
start out with kind of your background
how did you get into World War 2
accident of birth I think that my father
was an infantry officer enlisted at the
age of 19 he was in Germany at the end
of the war Staden was part of the
Constabulary the armored cavalry unit
that was the had amazing police powers
in Bavaria right after the war he came
back to the United States went to
college and then went back into the army
as the lieutenant in in 1951 stayed in
as a career officer so I grew up as an
army brat and you know as an army brat
on military posts in the 50s and 60s
world war ii was a real presence it was
a living breathing thing there were a
lot of veterans like my father it was
not history it was why we were there I
was born in Munich we lived in Salzburg
why were we in Central Europe well we're
in Central Europe is part of the
occupation I was back in Germany in the
mid 90s for three years as the bureau
chief for The Washington Post in Berlin
and I was there for that endless
succession of 50th anniversary
commemorations Normandy the Bulge the
end of the war and that really really
interest in the subject among other
things I saw that the story is
bottomless there's always more right
there will always be more to write about
World War two
and I also saw that you know for most
Americans I think there's a perception
that a World War Two consisted of Pearl
Harbor and then there was Normandy and
something bad happened at the Bulge and
the war ended and we won I realized I
think in a visceral way that that army
that came ashore in Normandy on June 6
1944 had a history the men and the
officers in that army that came ashore
had a history individually and
collectively and that to understand
where they had come from they didn't
just leap from the ether they had a they
had a heritage somehow you you had to
understand what came before and what
came before was North Africa
beginning in November 1942 with the
invasion called Operation Torch and then
that lasts until May of 1943 when North
Africa is taken and then Sicily and
Italy invasion of Sicily in July 1943
invasion of Italy in September 43 and
those are the antecedents to that last
act and that it's really a triptych
there are three clear panels somehow and
so that is what galvanized my interest
and gave me the organizational framework
to pursue what has now become a trilogy
speaking of that what is sort of the
scope of this work how does it kind of
fit into your earlier work and what's
kind of the the the next the next issue
if you will well this book the day of
battle the war in Sicily in Italy is the
natural successor to volume 1 volume 1
an army at dawn as I said opens with the
invasion of Morocco and Algeria on
November 8 1942 we meet characters who
come into our lives really for the first
time in a meaningful way Eisenhower is
the commander he's a three star in North
Africa at that time Omar Bradley makes
his appearance George Patton steps on to
the stage he's the commander of the
invasion force in Morocco and so we have
followed them all the way through the
North African campaign along with a very
large subset of mostly British and
American soldiers when Tunis Falls on
May 13 1943 North Africa is ours which
means that the Mediterranean is ours
which is the game plan to recapture the
Mediterranean open Suez for shipping to
India and to help resupply the the
Russians from the south for example so
the next natural step and it was a
natural step at the time is to go into
Sicily and that decision had been taken
at Casablanca when Roosevelt and
Churchill met in January 43 but after
that it was unclear what was going to
happen the British wanted to go into
Italy and Americans did not the
Americans
that the Mediterranean strategy was
ill-conceived and they believed that for
a long time but we largely because of
Churchill's
ability to persuade Roosevelt and
because of the successes in Sicily the
decision is made to go into mainland
Italy the British invade the toe of the
boot of Italy on September 3rd 43 and
then the larger force at Salerno under
General Mark Clark on September 9th 43
so for me it's a natural next step
because it's what happened
chronologically it's what happened in
history I take it through the fall of
Rome which was June 4th 1943 some of the
most brutal fighting of the war between
that invasion of Salerno in September 43
and the fall of Rome in June of 44 and I
cut it off there in this volume too
because in volume 3 we're going to take
the next natural step and that is go to
Western Europe on the eve of the
invasion Normandy indeed let's talk
about Sicily a little bit what were the
the the strategic objectives of that
campaign and do you think in some ways
the Germans kind of came out with a win
on that now that's a that's a very
interesting point and I think the answer
is yes that they did in the sense that
for German divisions got away the
strategic objective in Sicily in part
was to take advantage of the momentum
that had been garnered in North Africa
even though the Mediterranean was
largely under allied control after the
successful completion of the campaign in
North Africa the the Germans and the
Italians who were still in the war at
that point still had control obviously
of the northern lip of the Mediterranean
so the intent was to capture Sicily the
largest island in the Mediterranean
which would provide air bases for
bombing the Reich as well as mainland
Italy and it would further safeguard
shipping through the Mediterranean and
through Suez and it would further
consolidate the the the Allied hold on
the Mediterranean this was a fairly
simple decision to take in the sense
that
what else are you going to do if you've
got a half a million men in North Africa
shipping is extremely tight it's the
bottleneck through which all strategic
decisions have to be made in world war
ii and if you don't have the shipping to
move those 1/2 million men somewhere
else whether it's back to britain or
elsewhere well the easiest thing is just
to go a hundred miles across the
mediterranean to sicily and that's the
decision that's taken the invasion
occurred on July 10th 1943 a very large
invasion bigger than Normandy as it
turns out eight allied divisions
including the Canadians of British and
the Americans it goes pretty well the
the the Germans are surprised sort of
there are two German divisions on the
island there's a rather hapless large
contingent of Italians on the island
there's no real substantive plan beyond
landing on the beaches 20 miles inland
there's no plan there is no plan to cut
the Straits of Messina which are only
three miles from Mussina's three miles
from the Italian teller the boot and so
what you find in the campaign and Sicily
is a kind of extemporizing strategically
and a kind of inattention by Eisenhower
and Alexander Herald Alexander's the
senior British commander in the
Mediterranean and they haven't really
thought this through very carefully so
the Germans reinforce basically fight a
delaying war in part to let the Italians
get away partly so the Germans can
decide Hitler can decide what he's going
to do and then with four very good
German divisions this is not the b-team
these these are good soldiers the first
parachute division the 15th Panzer
Grenadier division troops like that four
of them on the island they essentially
are allowed to escape and we fight them
over and over again all the way up the
boot of Italy
over the next year plus you see that
15th Panzer grenadiers you see the
Hermann Goering division yeah talk a
little bit about the Hermann goring
division what a great
I mean unit that the Germans had what
was what was unique about it and why did
we fight you know we fought
tooth and nail all the way up Italy we
did and actually we they had been
destroyed in North Africa the Hermann
Goering division was in splinters after
the campaign in North Africa ended it
was reconstituted rather quickly as you
can tell by the eponymous name it was a
unit that was formed specifically
specifically under the auspices of Field
Marshal Goering who was the head of the
Luftwaffe it had Luftwaffe ties it was
called a parachute division although
there wasn't a guy in it with a
parachute as far as I know it was
heavily armoured it was well outfitted
as you might expect pet division of
Hermann Goering and it was reconstituted
very quickly after North Africa so that
what you find is it's part of this
reinforcing force that goes into Sicily
it's part of the force that gets away it
is part of the force that
counter-attacks at Salerno
unsuccessfully but it's a very closed
run thing at Salerno and then we see
them again and again we see them at
Anzio where they're part of the
reinforcement that comes in to try to
stop the breakout at Anzio in May of 44
now this is a year after they've been
destroyed in North Africa they're shot
to pieces again at this point in 44 but
one of the one of the heartbreaking
things you see is these these same
German units whom you think we've
destroyed come back to life essentially
and we end up fighting them over and
over again one thing that I really
enjoyed about the book is it not only
covers the strategic level but it also
gets to the foxhole view of the war
let's go down to that level - like
Randall Harris who was with the with
darby's Rangers who it's assaults Jayla
beech kind of what happened there give
the viewers a view an aspect of the book
of what what that was like for the
Rangers to assault Jayla Beach yeah
well the the Rangers had been created
before North Africa was predicated on
both an American tradition the Rangers
from the 18th century but all
so on a British concept the British had
commandos and Lucien Truscott was
involved in forming our Rangers there
was one Ranger Battalion under a very
compelling very charismatic young
lieutenant colonel named William Darby
from Fort Smith Arkansas
I think Darby was 33 34 years old at the
time and the Rangers did well in North
Africa they'd been on a number of
sculpting missions and they had been
part of the original invasion force and
they'd done well enough that there was a
decision made to replicate them to grow
the unit and so there were three Ranger
battalions by the time we go into Jayla
and in Sicily which is the centerpiece
of the American part of the invasion of
Sicily and what you find is the Rangers
land they encounter fairly stiff
resistance from the Italians its hapless
but they're fighting and then a fairly
stiff counter-attack by the Germans the
it's also relatively hapless fortunately
but there it's it's an intense firefight
and it goes on for the better part of a
day and a half or so you know the
Rangers attract a wide assortment some
might say motley but I would say an
extraordinarily diverse group of people
they would have
stevedores and roustabouts and
Lumberjacks who had from civilian world
who became Rangers because you're
looking for men who are physically fit
always white of course and so you have
you know the likes of Randall Harris
who's you know from Iowa originally you
know he's badly wounded at one point he
basically takes his belt buckle and puts
it over the room wound he's got his
intestines coming out he fights on it's
it's the stuff of which Ranger lore is
is made and the Rangers are really one
of the most interesting stories all the
way through
the Italian campaign at least through
the fall of Rome because the Rangers we
will also see at Anzio and there's three
extraordinarily capable Ranger
battalions are essentially destroyed at
Anzio it's it's the end of the Rangers
as Darby knew them indeed I mean I don't
want to jump ahead too far but let's
since we're on the Rangers let's talk a
little bit about that at Chester no I
mean I've interviewed about 200 Rangers
for the the book I wrote beyond valor
and it was one of the the stories that
the Ranger veterans didn't talk about
because it was so painful for them to
relieve these moments this raid in the
breakout from Anzio I mean it's it's
it's a it's an incredible story just
kind of walk us through that we're kind
of going up a little bit as far as the
book goes up into Anzio and kind of
leapfrogging ahead but what's what's
sort of the general Rangers story there
I thought I thought that's just an
incredible story of valour and and
really it's a it's an untold story in
many ways it's uh and it is one of the
saddest stories really of American men
at arms in World War two well in brief
you're right we are leap frogging a
little bit but we are talking about the
Rangers the Rangers land at Anzio on
January 22nd 1944 because the drive up
the Italian boot has been stymied the
Germans are very good playing defense
and they have essentially stopped the
anglo-american drive north on the Gustav
line near Cassino and so the decision is
made if we can't go through them us go
around them and there is a landing made
at Anzio it's an undermanned landing
there only it's a two division Corps
what you really needed was an army
multiple cores to do this Anzio is only
about 20 miles from Rome the decision
had been made land at Anzio see if he
can't push in inland cut highway 6 and
highway 7 which are the main feeder
routes from Rome to the German front so
the the Rangers land there and about a
week goes past there is not a
counter-attack as there had been at
Salerno basically
you know there are officers sleeping in
pajamas on the first and second nights
at Anzio
and it's relatively quiet and for four
reasons that we can get into later if
you want the decision is made by general
Lucas who is the commander on the scene
Major General Lucas American commander
of of six Corps not to push out
immediately and when they do push out
and we're talking now about January 29th
1944 a week after the landings the
Rangers are to lead the 3rd Infantry
Division essentially which is the
American division that is landed at
Anzio Torch Astana justanna is an
ancient crossroads town it was known as
three taverns to st. Paul it's that old
and the belief was bad intelligence
again that justanna was lightly held
basically it was a screening force by
Germans the Rangers were to infiltrate
up a ditch Pantano ditch an irrigation
ditch this is through the pontine
marshes which is a very flat a very wet
area that had been reclaimed by
Mussolini it's it's small farms
essentially and the two Ranger
battalions were to lead up through the
ditch to get behind the Germans screen
line while a 3rd Ranger Battalion went
up the road torch Astana from Anzio
leading essentially the 3rd division
which is a heavier force essentially
what happens on the night of the the
29th 30th is that the Rangers without
realizing it have walked into a sawmill
the Germans have reinforced that very
day as a matter of fact the light
screening force is in fact turned into a
heavy reinforced substantial defensive
line by the Germans the one of the
battalion commanders of these two going
up the ditch is killed early on causing
disarray it's long snaking column that's
walking at midnight through the ditch
comes unhinged the loss of a leader is
always a
desperate thing on the battlefield loss
of radio communications was also and
they were supposed to keep radio silence
initially so that's true and when they
finally try to get through back to to to
Darby who's in the rear trying to
monitor all this they're having trouble
getting through to them the long and the
short of it is the Rangers break through
what is they thought it was an ambush
it's actually a German bivouac they're
walking through an olive orchard
and-and-and fields
the Germans are surprised because
they're sleeping there's a big gunfight
the Rangers are trapped they're
surrounded as a triangular field several
hundred meters on each side it's
compressed during the early morning more
and more until the Rangers are really
you know a last stand the dart be by
this point is listening on the radio and
he hears one of his one of the early
Rangers a sergeant major name he Walt is
radioing reports to Darby you know sir
we got many casualties were surrounded
the battalion that's trying to come up
the road has also been stopped dead a
lot of casualties in that battalion the
3rd Infantry Division cannot break
through the Germans ultimately form a
perimeter with armor they're using some
Rangers have been captured as shields
some of the Rangers who are still
fighting or firing on their own men
so you have Rangers killing other
Rangers this is one of the reasons they
don't like to talk about it it's just
it's such an incredibly painful thing 60
years after the fact
ultimately those who survived surrender
they are marched to Rome they are
paraded around the Coliseum with German
cameras rolling videotaping this the
equivalent of videotaping filming it
Darby who has heard the last he's heard
the end he's heard a Walt say sir
I'm gonna destroy the radio now they're
on me puts his head down in his command
bows and sobs just sobs and he goes and
he sees where his men have left their
duffel bags and big piles earlier in the
day they have the name stenciled on them
it's it's a terrible thing
it's the end of the Ranger Regiment
essentially at that point Darby loses
his command because there is no command
he goes to the 45th division for a wild
Anzio does very well and eventually goes
back to the Pentagon for a while of all
things one of the greatest soldiers in
American fighting history and then he
returns to Italy Darby is killed among
the last men killed in the war and in
late April early May 1945 a stray shell
lands kills him this painful episode
well it taught some lessons to talk
lessons about sending a light force into
on wreckin oider territory
the Rangers of course are reconstituted
in different battalions land at Ponte
Hawk and Normandy in June of 44 fight
famously there and the Rangers live to
this day but that remains probably the
single most painful moment in the whole
glorious history of the American Rangers
indeed you know Darby was a man of
action that usually went with his men is
there what do you think he didn't do it
this time it's a good question Pat I you
know I think it's because he was a
regimental commander at this point is a
there's a difference between being a
battalion commander leading them on a
raid in Tunisia for example as he had
and being a regimental commander keeping
track of three battalions command and
control is an order of magnitude more
difficult at that point and I think he
was doing the right thing staying behind
Manning the radios he's the liaison
between his force and general Truscott
who's commanding the the 3rd Infantry
Division at that point you know if you
know Darby historically you know that
you know he wished he were out there he
says it on the radio to sergeant major
he walls but I think you know the
necessities of command required that the
commander not always be at the point of
the spear and I I think that in this
case Darby in fact had done the right
to eat you know you were an embedded
reporter with a hundred first airborne
you've been a rock I spent three months
in a rifle platoon wrote a book called
we were one how did that experience
change you and how did it impact this
book in the other books that you've
written yeah the I think the experience
of being around latter-day soldiers a
lot as I am I was in Iraq in July of
2007 most recently I was in Afghanistan
in July of 2007 I was embedded with the
101st Airborne Division I was at then
Major General David Petraeus is elbow
every day all day long for a couple of
months during the invasion of Iraq and
up through the fall of Baghdad I think
it informs you as a writer about the
verities the eternal verities of
infantry life among other things
yeah the equipment's different the
soldiers are better educated it's a
volunteer force there are lots of women
it's very diverse there are lots of
blacks and Hispanics it's it's it's
quite a different army and many
demographic respects from say that army
of 1943 but on the other hand if you're
with is you know if you're with a rifle
company going into pilau or nas off it
seems very very familiar to that rifle
company going into Jayla or rifle
company fighting at Salerno there are
things about the relationship between
leaders and lead things about the
camaraderie that blooms on a battlefield
as really nowhere else to the point
where you're really fighting first and
foremost for the guy next to you because
you love him deep deep love you're
willing to give your life for them so I
think you know being with soldiers on
latter-day battlefields helps you to
understand that
and to understand what animates them
historically particularly on a soldier
level also you know for me I'm around I
hang around commanders a lot I get sent
letters saying they're not really
soldiers they're generals
well that's you know Dave Petraeus is a
soldier he always has been since
arriving at West Point in 1970 you learn
a lot about I think the pressures on
commanders you learn about things like
sleep deprivation and the need for for
sleep discipline you learn about the
interpersonal relationships between a
commander and his subordinates and
between a commander and his superiors
those are you know you read The Iliad
and you can see you know the
relationship between Agamemnon and
Achilles is a relationship of a
subordinate and a superior and I think
that these also are part of the eternal
things in soldiering and so I find it's
very useful it's it just makes me feel
more comfortable in writing historically
about some of the essential skein of of
the soldiering life perfectly put I mean
I think you captured the feelings and
emotions of some of these men as well as
a love like you said that these these
guys have towards one another and
fighting for one other how would you
kind of say I so many times when I was
in Iraq I heard that this is the next
Greatest Generation how would you
compare this generation with the world
war two generation you know I love Tom
Brokaw as a person and as somebody who's
interested in World War two I think the
greatest generation label is bunk
personally first of all which generation
are we talking about in World War two
we're talking about the generation of
the commander's basically we're they're
19th century men Patton born in 1885
Eisenhower born in 1890 or the
generation of trigger pullers my father
born in 1924 so there's more than one
generation I'd say the trigger pullers
let's say the trigger pullers you know
if you look if you compare soldiers
today say
for an infantry in a rifle company today
- his ancestor in 1944 he's probably
going to be much better educated he's
more physically fit he's a volunteer and
he was probably drafty in World War two
he's he's bigger stronger healthier his
teeth are better he's got all of the
signatures of you know a third or fourth
generation removed from that Depression
era army which was physically battered
depression had taken a great physical
toll on the American population 140
million people a lot of them were not
all that healthy as a consequence of the
depression and that played out in the
8th million man army the world you know
it got to the point they would take
anybody who had enough teeth to
masticate the army ration that means if
you could chew a see ration even if they
only had two teeth you were in and you
know that's not what you see in the army
today
I think clearly you know their weaponry
everything that they've got in terms of
protective gear and so on is light years
removed from World War two again though
the things that are really essential
about soldiering they're quite similar
excellent we're going to now go to a
break and then continue later afterwards
and several others c-span programs are
available for download as podcasts visit
book TV org more with Rick Atkinson and
patrick o'donnell in a moment
next weekend on book TV an in-depth
discussion with Newt Gingrich a ten term
US congressman mr. Gingrich led the 1994
Republican takeover of the House of
Representatives and was speaker from
1995 to 1999 he's the author of over a
dozen fiction and nonfiction books book
TV we'll take your calls for our
three-hour discussion you can also email
us your questions at book TV org Newt
Gingrich in-depth Sunday December 2nd 12
p.m. on book TV afterwards with rick
atkinson and patrick o'donnell continues
okay we're going to continue now with
the actual invasion of Italy and the
salerno landings and i think you did a
brilliant job of really going into the
landings and i think it's really the
best narrative history that i've ever
seen on the salerno landings kind of
give us an overview of it and why it was
such a touch-and-go thing and how the
germans in fact almost hurled the Allies
back into this yeah they sure did
well when the decision had been made to
invade Italy then the question is where
and the beaches at Salerno were chosen
partly because they were good beaches
for amphibious landing but partly
because they were at the very end of the
tether of air cover from air bases in
Sicily it was carefully calculated how
long a Spitfire could loiter over the
beaches to provide some air cover for 10
minutes before having to return indeed
so many of the invasions world war ii
were based on right that the miles that
a fighter plane or fighter bomber could
travel well exactly right and
particularly at this point we're talking
now about summer of 1943 even with
additional tanks on the wings it was a
pretty limited range and of course the
Germans knew this and Kesselring who
albert kesselring field marshal who was
the senior german commander recognized
that the Allies tended to be tethered to
their airpower
and as a consequence he anticipated to a
large extent that Salerno was a likely
landing spot so what happens in the
event is on September 3rd 1943 the
British Eighth Army under Bernard L
Montgomery crosses the Messina Strait
two miles two and a half miles from
Sicily there's no opposition to speak of
and he begins the very long very
ponderous crawl up the coast of Italy on
the east wasn't in a hurry was it wasn't
in a hurry he always wanted things to be
just so before moving further the
Germans left a very small rearguard
detachment blew up some bridges the
terrain was tough but Montgomery was
slow and they would work their way up
the Adriatic coast
a week later less than a week five days
later basically the 5th army under
General Mark Clark one of the most
controversial generals of world war ii
west point 1917 two years behind
eisenhower close personal friend of
Eisenhower's he lands at Salerno with a
combined British and American force
Brits tend outnumber the Americans at
this point they don't really understand
that the Germans have all the advantages
of topography at Salerno we've got the
beaches they've got the high ground and
if you ever go to Salerno which is about
40 miles south of Naples beautiful
magnificent Bay surrounded by mountains
and you go inland ten miles and it's all
high ground and anybody on the high
ground where the paradise binoculars can
see everything that's happening on the
beach and so what happens is that once
again there's been a an under Manning of
an invasion force it's not nearly as
large as the invasion force its Sicily
partly because the British are down in
the toe of the boot with Montgomery and
the Germans quickly with with great
alacrity which is the signature of
Kesselring and the Germans in Italy in
general begin to reinforce the beachhead
and they quickly ringed the beachhead
so that you have a force that is largely
trapped and the fighting grows desperate
the landings had been had begun on
September 9th by September 13th the
Allied Force is very near to being
thrown back into the sea
the Germans recognized a little
belatedly actually that there was a
river water course that divided the
British force from the in the north near
the town of Salerno from the American
force in the south near the ancient
magnificent Greek temple of paestum and
the Germans counter-attack down this
water course is called the Sailor River
and only luck and magnificent defense by
a couple of American artillery
battalions firing over open sights
almost at point-blank stopped this
German Panzer counter-attack coming down
down the river the fighting rages for
another couple of days
Kesselring finally realizes it just
doesn't have quite enough strength to do
it
the Americans are reinforcing slowly
that's not a big force coming in Mark
Clark who has ordered his men to begin
preparing to withdrawal and this causes
great controversy and consternation
within the ranks the British in
particular say withdrawal you can't
withdraw if you take a a landing craft
in and the landing craft drops its ramp
on the beach and you load it up with men
and materiel you can't get off the beach
it doesn't have the strength to pull
back off the beach you'll end up losing
half your force Clark spent a good part
of the rest of his life defending the
decision saying he was only making
contingency plans and he didn't really
plan to pull out at any rate the long
and the short of it was the Germans
strength stopped a couple miles short of
the beach where they would have really
divided in half the British and American
portions of the beachhead
and could have rolled up the flanks
defeated them in detail the Germans end
up pulling back back through Naples
they destroyed Naples on their way out
it was scorched earth policy of the
first order they they wrecked everything
that hadn't been wrecked by Allied
bombing blew up the sewer system blew up
the libraries blew up the electrical
systems the American and British forces
entered Naples on the 1st of October
which was the whole plan to get to
Naples was the plan because Naples has
one of the biggest best ports in Europe
and if you're gonna run a big army you
got to have a big port in order to bring
the the the bullets beans and bombs in
let's talk a little bit about Field
Marshal Kesselring and who was he as a
person I mean brilliant German commander
and how did he almost throw back the
Allies in Salerno Kesselring is a very
interesting commander he's a Bavarian he
had he was as many German senior
commanders Rorie's is an Italo file
he likes the Italians he had started as
an artilleryman in the German army and
then he switched to to the lift-off and
he learned to fly rather late in life I
think he was in his 40s when he learned
to fly so he understands air power he's
shot down five times during the war in
fact including a couple times in Italy
and survives those they called him
smiling Albert because if you see
pictures of him he's got this big toothy
grin which was one of his signatures he
has sort of a Bavarian aura about him
Kesselring is extremely adept at
realizing where the chinks are in the
Allied armor in general he's got a good
intuition for it he's got a good ability
as the best commanders do to project
himself into the minds of his
adversaries and to to anticipate what it
is they're going to do how they're
thinking how they're feeling at Salerno
what we find is that he's not only got
the gift of audacity but he's got the
ability the organizational ability
pull these disparate units from all over
Italy really
and from all over the Mediterranean
ultimately he does the same thing at
Anzio several months later and gets them
to hustle as quickly as they can and to
reinforce as quickly as they can it's
much faster it's much more agile than
the Allies believe the Germans are
capable of it's much more agile than the
Allies are frankly what you find in
Kesselring is an airman who knows that
the closer the Allies get to northern
Italy the better their airfields are
going to be the superiority of the
Allied air forces which Kesselring knows
is stupendous
it's going to wreak havoc on both German
cities and on a German industrial might
for every airfield that they build in
Italy that's another group of b-17s and
b-24s that are going to be able to
hammer munich or the the the oil fields
in and play ashed for example in romania
and so Kesselring's whole strategic
ambition is to keep the Allies as far
away from the Reich as possible that's
why they've been fighting in Sicily to
start with he convinces Hitler that this
is a good idea
Hitler again had been willing to give up
southern Italy particularly with the
Italian switched sides on the eve of the
invasion of Salerno the Italians are out
of the axis essentially and so
kesselring essentially comes up with a
strategy that Hitler buys into of
fighting a series of rearguard actions
building these strong fortified lines
using the Italian topography of course
it's a very narrow mountainous boot it
plays to the defence and if you build a
series of fortified lines his hope his
ambition is that the Allies will as you
put it break their teeth on these these
lines and it has to be said that they do
break their teeth on these lines for
quite a while indeed let's talk about
one of those lines the winter line and
how and the importance of
Pietro which is one of the great battles
of World War two that's really not been
right explored fully yeah San Pietro I
was just there actually a couple weeks
ago I've been there several times
consider it after the war for just a
moment before we talk about the battle
San Pietro was the linchpin of the
winter line essentially it's it's it's
in the minyak no gap which is a very
narrow defile it's only about a mile
across between very high hill masses
mountains on either side and if you're
going from south to north you have to go
through the minyak no gap essentially
and San Pietro has the misfortune it's
in 11th century medieval town little
farming town about a thousand people in
it in 1943 it has the misfortune of
sitting like a stopper in a bottle in
the manana gap and so it was heavily
fought over it was utterly destroyed
there were a number of San Pietro who
were still living in the village they're
living in caves you can still see the
caves under the town and after the war
the town was so utterly eviscerated that
the San Pietro --nz didn't return they
built the new San Pietro down the hill
about half a kilometre and so if you go
to San Pietro today it's a ghost town
and it's much as it was you can see that
the Church of st. Michael the Archangel
it's the nave is smashed the the tower
is in fragments it's a really stunning
monument to what happened to Italy so
what we find in December 1943 is that
the the Allied forces coming from the
south but up against break their teeth
on this German line one of these several
lines that Kesselring has has
constructed and this is a delaying
action because about six miles north is
the real line it's the Gustav line which
runs through casino and Kesselring is
buying time so that his engineers and
and forced laborers of thousands of
Italians who are working building
foxholes and other fortifications on the
Gustav line and so what happens in San
Pietro is that Clark recognizes the
American commander that this is a
critical place that you've got to got to
take San Pietro to get through the 36th
trade division which had been the Texas
National Guard is given the honor of
attacking San Pietro it's kind of a
hard-luck division they'd been at
Salerno they've been shot up badly at
Salerno after this a month later they
will be at the rapido River one of the
worst rubbings of any unit in World War
two more than 2,000 casualties and so at
San Pietro you've got on a very small
stage really big events colliding San
Pietro is where Ernie Pyle rode his most
famous dispatch from World War two it's
very moving
it's a to this day it's one of the most
moving pieces of expository writing from
World War two it's about a captain in
the 36th division named Henry Wasco son
of a dirt-poor farmer who becomes a
company commander and he's killed on
Monty's Samoa which looms behind San
Pietro and his body lays on the side of
the mountain in December of 44 43 and
finally is brought by mule down to a
base camp and venafro and Pyle happens
to be there and Pyle describes in the
moonlight the bodies coming on the mules
down the trail down the trail the bodies
are taken off and they're laid in the
shadow of a low stone wall that's his
refrain the shadow of the low stone wall
and rhaskos cases men come up and say
goodbye to him and pile records all this
in an extraordinarily moving column that
he wrote from there
so it's two weeks of hell in San Pietro
and finally the the Germans are in
danger of being outflanked there's
really only one battalion holding the
town itself and what do they do when
they're in danger of being outflanked
they just moved back about two miles to
the next town which is also made of
stone and they will hold that town for
weeks more this is the story of Italy
whose captain helmet might soul you know
I don't know that much about him except
that he's an extra is the battalion
commander who's there and in San Pietro
he's very young he's like 23 commanding
a battalion
as a captain and the Germans were
barbarous in San Pietro they had arrived
there shortly after the invasion of
Italy by the Allies shortly after the
Italians to switch sides and hard
feelings by the Germans about that
the Gestapo arrived in San Pietro they
took the priest the priest was never
found again they found found only his
cloak this big black cloak which was
snagged in a tree in this grove below
the village of San Pietro
some might soul arrives as part of this
tough force and he's you know he's got
just extraordinarily capable soldiers
might salade been at Stalingrad he'd
been wounded and evacuated one of the
last planes out of Stalingrad this is a
guy who'd seen a lot of war and he knew
how to fight under the most arduous
conditions obviously having survived
Stalingrad I don't know what happens to
him later I I lose track of him frankly
I'm just fascinated by the fact that the
Germans put in a captain now in charge
of perhaps one of the most important
battalions of the war at San Pietro and
he does a brilliant job you know
basically bottling up the Allies Hitler
is acting as a field marshal from his
lair and East Prussia at this point
Hitler is essentially the field
commander even though he said you know a
thousand miles away
Kesselring wanted to abandon San Pietro
early on he thought there was a better
place to fight to play defense farther a
little farther north Hillier initially
agreed and then changed his mind so yes
you have this captain this very young
man there as the linchpin of the German
defense and you've got the Fuhrer
watching very carefully everything that
happens there and it's the Fuhrer who's
making tactical decisions down on a
battalion level from the Vosges onthe
his lair in East Prussia outside San
Pietro we find another famous American
unit called the first Special Service
Force who were they a very interesting
unit and they they are the antis see
and genealogically of our special forces
today it was a combined American
Canadian unit commanded by one of the
most remarkable soldiers sort of like
Darby in his physical presence named
Robert Frederick son of a San Francisco
doctor he'd had kind of an itinerant
boyhood it shipped out to Australia at
the age of 14 I ended up going to West
Point and when we see him near San
Pietro in the minyak no gap he's a
brigadier general he's hardly more than
a boy himself I can't remember he's in
his early 30s maybe he's described as
like a cat he's just got all the
physical attributes of a cat
this first Special Service Force had
been trained for just this kind of
mountain winter warfare they trained in
Montana again they're drawn from guys
who'd been civilian Lumberjacks and
mining prospectors and that sort of
thing Canadian and American even had a
few guys that were in the brig that were
thrown into the unit or volunteered in
the best tradition and so they come into
the war and they are given a very tough
task which is to to take the hill mass
that is just to the west of the minyak
no gap it's called monte la difensa and
it's it's very steep it was well
defended by Germans on the top frederick
leads his men in the dark of night
around the back of it and they climb up
this almost vertical precipice they are
discovered just as they're near the top
and there is a ferocious fight that
lasts for the better part of a week they
take the top of the hill it's a big it's
about the size of a football field a
saucer-shaped depression that's the top
of LA difensa they have tremendous
casualties they do hold it the British
are taking Monte Camino just to the west
of them so you have the the western
shoulder of the minyak no gap and the
first Special Service Force is a big
part of that
indeed where does the force go after
this where they where do they kind of
move towards well they go to they end up
in Anzio and Frederick is there they are
holding the one of the flanks of the of
the force there along the Mussolini
canal and when the breakout from Anzio
occurs in May of 1944 the first Special
Service Force is part of that and
they're called the black Devils and all
right kinds of other terms in right sure
because the Germans fear them they do
yes let's go back a little bit before we
get to Anzio and talk about the rapido
River River crossings I mean really I
thought you did an excellent job kind of
detailing the crossings and in what went
wrong and sort of what it was like from
you know an average infant infantryman
trying to cross this river you know
there's a lot of heartbreak in Italy and
there's there very few places that are
more heartbreaking than the repeater I
was just there also recently the 36
Division drew the short straw again they
were ordered to attack essentially a
frontal attack as part of an effort to
break the Gustav line the rapido River
looks like a creek basically it's not
very wide it's quite deep it's 12 feet
deep and in January of 1944 it's running
very swiftly because the Germans have
demolished dams and dikes upstream and
so the rapido is really in spate the the
36th division attacks with two regiments
it's commanded by a capable
major-general named Walker who keeps a
very detailed diary so we know all of
his doubts and anxieties before the
rapido ever occurs and during the attack
and after the attack again these are
Texans he's from Ohio but it's a very
Texas division and the the regiment's
attack about a mile apart
they get nowhere there are a lot of men
who drown in the rapido River on January
20th and 21st 1944 the Germans have a
bluff in the village of Santangelo
which sits on this Bluff is heavily
fortified the Germans don't even realize
that the attack is in the force that it
is they don't realize that a that a full
division essentially is attacking two
regiments of a division there are no
reinforcements required of the Germans
the attack fails there's another attack
launched the next day it fails some men
there are a couple of battalions that
get across the river they are trapped
they get no more than a 500-yard
bridgehead across the river they are
under plunging fire and grazing fire
there were lots of wounds to the
buttocks from men trying to press as
close as they can to the ground and this
grazing fires coming across and and
hitting them in the butts essentially
they're recalled those who can there are
about twenty to hundred casualties at
the rapido River it's devastating it's
comparable to Omaha Beach in the
intensity of the casualties with the big
difference that the rapido gain nothing
Omaha Beach gained Normandy essentially
part of that invasion force the Texans
were so angry about it that they
conspired really right after the battle
to bring charges to insist on a
congressional investigation of General
Mark Clark who was the fifth Army
commander who had ordered the attack and
in indeed that happened after the war
there were congressional hearings both
the House and the Senate had hearings
congressional delegation from Texas
pushed it through Walker testified it
was mortifying to Clark who at this
point is that the Governor General
essentially in Austria after the war the
the findings by the army were that Clark
had acted within the bounds of his
authority and that his tactical
decisions were not to be second-guessed
after the war it still stings Clark's
name is not held in good odor in parts
of Texas as a consequence of this the
36th division redeems itself in a really
profound way at the very end of the
campaign going into Rome Walker was a
mining engineer as a college student at
Ojai
State and he knows topography and he
finds again their bottle up and he sees
a logging trail over Monte Artemisia
coming out of Anzio and he recognizes
that there's potential to this mining
this is a logging trail he convinces his
superiors to let the division try and
push bulldozers up here to create and
create a tank Road which gets them
behind the Germans this is May of 44 and
it works there they found a seam between
German units between German cores the
bulldozers going up this very steep
trail managed to cut a trail that you
can pull you can bring tanks and
artillery over they get behind the
German defenses at Velletri it unhinges
the whole German line and three days
later Rome Falls this is the 36th
division hard-luck at Salerno hard luck
tough fighting at San Pietro terrible
luck terrible fighting at the rapido
River and then at at Monte Artemisia
it's one of the great redemptive stories
of World War two and how long did that
how long did that operation last
basically at Artemisia yes they did it
in a night really you know they set out
right after sundown which is fairly late
because because it's May 1944 Sun
doesn't go down until 9:30 they put two
regiments right behind the other had all
these bulldozers lined up and
single-file the infantry led up over
Monte Artemisia you could hear cuckoos
if you go there today you can hear
cuckoos in the woods and these chestnut
groves and by dawn they were on top of
the of the hill it's a fairly steep
ridge line and Kesselring recognized
that he was in trouble he ordered his
men to close the line it was too late
the Americans had it and
I never gave it up what lessons do you
think we can learn from you know this
campaign compared to today well
certainly you know I think it's
difficult to conflate the the campaign
in Italy or world war two generally with
Iraq and Afghanistan politically they're
completely different it's a different
page is a different it's a different
world you know I think what we can see
and I think you probably know this very
well from from the reporting and writing
you've done is that the soldiers in that
army in that victorious army in 1944 in
Italy for example are really of a peace
with the soldiers today that if you
honor them you must honor those soldiers
today it's important not to confuse the
warriors with the war however you feel
about the war in Iraq or in Afghanistan
not tangling up your feelings your
admiration your support for the Warriors
I think is really important you know we
can see if we look back on the lessons
from the Italian campaign that a lot of
the things that again they're eternal
verities of warfare still obtain the
need for good intelligence how important
is that then the need for the the
properly prepared force they have to be
properly outfitted the need for public
support from home all of these things
you know whether again you're writing
about
the Trojan War or whether you're writing
about Iraq in 2007 or part-and-parcel
it's part of the warp and woof of
warfare and the relationship between an
armed force in the country once they
come excellent is there anything else
that you want readers to to take away
from the book what was your kind of your
final goal if you will of for people
that read the book
well my ambition in this trilogy really
is to first of all recognize that World
War two is the greatest story of the
20th century it should be treated as
such and to merge storytelling with the
rigors of scholarship I think it's got
to hold up to close scrutiny by scholars
you you know if you want to do this kind
of work you have to be an archive rat at
heart because there are new things to
discover the archive for world war ii is
so vast no one has ever looked at more
than a fraction of it as you well know
and so there are things to discover
there are really wonderful things to
discover and if you can put that within
the context of a story if you can if you
can treat it as the magnificent saga the
epic that it is then I think you know my
ambition is for people to see this is
part and parcel of their their heritage
it's where we came from it's who we are
it's how we got to where we are today
this campaign was important in in World
War two it got to be a backwater